[موسيقى]
مريم نحن نستعد لهذه المداخله همم القصف
لم يتوقف منذ صباح اليوم على احياء عديده
من مدينه دنياس من بينها احياء مركزيه
قريبه من هذا المكان الذي نقف فيه تقريبا
في ذلك لاتجاه ولو
يظهر الان المصور قريبا تلك المنطقه التي
لا تبعد الا بنحو كيلومتر الى كيلو متر
ونصف من هنا هناك تصعد لاعمده الدخان
سبقها قبل لحظات قليله فقط انفجار همم دور
هنا في ما يبدو انه قصف مدفعي يستهدف تلك
المنطقه القريبه من مركز
السلطات اليوم تحدثت عن مقتل ثلاثه مدنيين
همم في عموم مدينه دنياس او في المقاطعه
بالاحرى خلال قصف الاوكراني استهدف احياء
كوبيسكي وايضا البترول
هذه الاحياء التي تعد قريبه الى حد من خط
اتماس الف في بين الجانبين وفي الحقيقه
هذا بات تقريبا امرا يوميا لكن حده القصف
احيانا تزداد واحيانا اخرى تتراجع همم على
ما يبدو هذا راجع الى همم
نعم وهناك الان يشير للمصور الى تصاعد
اعمده الدخان ايضا من تلك المنطقه حيث
يبدو انه هناك قصف ايضا طالها وتلك
المنطقه هي المنطقه الحدوديه بين مدينتي
دونيتك
فيما يخص
التطورات في همم
جبهه خرسون همم وسائل الاعلام روسيه بدات
صورا قالت انها لانزال العالم الروسي من
احد همم البنايات وحده البنايات الحكوميه
امس وايضا تحدثت عن القطاع كامل في همم
شبكه الانترنت وايضا الجوال في المنطقه
همم او الدفه اليسرى التي انتقلت اليها
القوات الروسيه والتي من افترض ان تصبح
همم اعتبارا من اليوم همم المعقل الاساسي
للقوات الروسيه في مقاطعه خرسون وايضا
اكدت سماعا انفجارات قويه هزت تلك الضفه
التي الان من المفترض ان يبدا الجيش
الروسي شكرا
بالتجمع فيها بعد طبعا ما ورد من الباب
حول انسحابه من مناطق في الضفه اليمنى
وايضا تفجيره لبعض الجسور وفقا مصادر
محليه هناك في خارج